like back in the day i thought like
[ __ ] school dinners were kind of like
prison food almost right you'd go in the
[ __ ] cafeteria
there was always these like you know the
lunch ladies they'd always look
depressed as [ __ ]
and you'd come in with like your tray
and now that i think about it you kind
of just felt like you're in prison we
didn't even have that
we just had like a cafeteria like like a
like a we called it a tuck shop
yeah a talk shop right yeah like you
guys have talk shops right no
what the [ __ ] is that that's a very
australian thing i just realized
so it's like a tuck shop in australian
schools it's basically this like
booth that you can just go and just buy
like food items
like right just it's not even a cafe
it's not even a room
it's stall it's like a store basically
because like our schools didn't really a
lot of schools in australia i think
don't really have like full-on
cafeterias because none of them are like
big enough to have full-on cafeteria so
like like
the only like experience of like
cafeterias i ever had as a kid was like
watching the simpsons okay like that was
the closest i ever got to like a school
cafeteria because like australian
schools like there are no schools
i don't i didn't know a single school in
my area or in australia at all that had
that like school lunches like some guy
just [ __ ] drops off some [ __ ] in this
truck
are you [ __ ] good for our kids i've
got some [ __ ] sausages here
yeah you literally just go to like a
stall kind of thing and there'd be like
a a canteen lady there or a cafeteria
lady
just like you just buy stuff i just like
smooth talk them or i should always be
really really [ __ ] nice to the
cafeteria ladies
and gentlemen extra food yeah oh yeah
whenever whenever like my friend's mom
was like the cafeteria lady they're like
hey come on come on let me in let me
just give you some of the back stock
no joke i would literally be like i
would go i'd be like that food was
amazing that was fantastic
i would literally i would always like go
back thank you so much that was great
that was fantastic
because right did they give you anything
for them oh yeah yeah so okay after a
while of doing this they would like
they would like make specialized things
for me
wow because i i would always my mates
gave me some [ __ ] for it because they're
like
why are you [ __ ] sucking up to them
i'm like well look at my [ __ ] meal
i'm i'm eating like a king today
they custom make the [ __ ] it's not just
[ __ ]
live they're like yo it's kind of
connor's rolling in
bring out the good [ __ ] bring it up
bring out the three-course meal
like they're about to serve me and the
other one's like no stop it's gone
do you know who this man is he says
thank you
so they used to make like so this is
again like another [ __ ] really
british thing jacket potatoes have you
heard of that jacket potatoes yeah i
know
jack of potatoes it's literally just
like it's it's a potato
it's a potato there's like like like
like like like like like like like like
like like like like like like you stab
it a bunch uh
maybe you cut it open a little bit you
put butter in it you baked potatoes
oh baked potatoes you wrap it up it's
called japanese yeah it's just potato
with butter
and they would just give it to you like
just that and i was like come on i'm
better than this and i was like i know
you got some chuda in the back there i
know you got some beans and cheese can
you put that [ __ ] all over it
so they would make like they normally
would just you could get a jack potato
but
because i was really nice to them they
would they would put like tuna in there
which i [ __ ] love
beans and cheese as well and i would
rock up like yeah boys i mean like a
king today
it's very good you literally like james
bond that [ __ ] you can't be like huh
the reason why i did it because i
realized that like one of the other kids
who was like way older than me got like
a bunch of
uh like really it looked like he always
had like everyone else's tray was like
peasant tray and this guy always had
like a stacked [ __ ] tray i was like
what is this guy doing
just like they don't give you extra if
you ask they just laugh at you right so
i was like oh [ __ ] what's he doing and i
watched him and he was just like smooth
talking i'm just saying like thank you a
bunch
i was like who knows all you do is just
say thank you and be nice and say the
truth
and they give you more